my mother is Jewish and my father is
Catholic that is the truth I was raised
Catholic formally although I must say
the Jewish mind comes out even in the
Catholic system giving example we used
to go into confession and I would bring
a lawyer in with me
[Applause]
Bless My Father for I have sinned I
think you know Mr Cohen
so there's always laws Associated being
a woman especially a married woman if
you're okay if you're a married woman in
Judaism and you're on your period you're
considered unclean
yeah which that's actually
hey I mean I have a problem with that
spiritually but physically that's
actually a very nice way of describing
what's actually happening
unclean as far I mean like legitimately
if I put two giant buckets on the stage
and one giant bucket said clean vaginas
and the other giant bucket said unclean
vaginas and then I handed each of you a
bleeding vagina
and I said put that anywhere
which bucket do we all know would be
overflowing with vaginas foreign
until you stopped having a period Then
you have to have seven days of no blood
and then you gotta go to a ritual Bath
called a Mikvah and then you're consider
clean again
um and at seven days of no blood in a
row
that means if you get spotting two days
out [ __ ]
yeah clock starts over [ __ ]
yeah it's like microwave popcorn it's
gonna be the full three seconds so it
does not count
and while you're on clean
um you can't touch your husband and your
husband can't touch you oh yeah can't
even sleep next to each other you gotta
go sleep in the corner like the bleeding
[ __ ] that you are
so this law it's called Nida this is the
reason this is the sociologically this
is the reason that Orthodox Jews have
large families it's not only so you can
fill up our minivans there's another
recipe
it boils down to this how long it
appears us what appearance go for these
days
five days okay
she's heavily disagreeing with you in
the back so what do you think it is
seven said the mansplainer
all right let's split the difference
five to seven that's what I thought I
was gonna be a woman saying the answer
to that but seven I know
five five to seven days I believe she
said uh
plus seven days of no blood that's 12 to
14 days okay
um plus another day or two ago the
ritual bath to go to the mick but
they're not like 24 Hour Fitness you
know they're only at certain spots
so now we're talking about right around
13 to 15 days after such a period is the
first time you're allowed to touch your
husband uh it's also when you are the
most fertile in your cycle
your ovaries are right at the bottom of
your [ __ ]
and you haven't touched your husband in
two weeks so he hasn't touched you
you're supposed super horny and right
then God's like go
there's no chance dude there's no chance
imagine the husband's home washing
dishes comes come out of his ears
[ __ ] hate this religion so much
Buddhist [ __ ] all the time
all the kids like Daddy just shut the
[ __ ] up Daddy
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you can beat your kids in Judaism just
so you know that is allowed I can't be
your wife but you can be your children
and right then the woman walks through
the door you know the guy's all cranky
just [ __ ] pent up and he's just like
where have you been
she's like ritual bath and he's like oh
yeah
foreign
last week on Larry King live Marlon
Brando made the shocking statement that
Hollywood is quote run by Jews
in response outraged Jewish
organizations made it snow in New York
in April
yeah well I'm Jewish friends so I'm not
freaked out by your culture I know a
little bit about it just from hanging
around like oh yo let's go out at school
tomorrow like we can't go out of Sha Na
Na tomorrow
foreign
I had so many questions why do some of
you people dress like Run DMC
[Applause]
he had broke my show business rules
is this a rule you know the rules of
perception if if they're black then it's
a gang
if they're Italian it's a mob but if
they're Jewish it's a coincidence and
you should never speak about it
I ain't got so much trouble Kyrie got in
trouble
[Applause]
Kyrie Kyrie Irving posted a a link to a
movie that he had seen on Amazon no
caption on the post or nothing like that
but apparently this movie had some I
don't know anti-semitic tropes or
something it was so weird tired like
from Hebrew to negro or something
and the NBA told me you should apologize
and he was slow to apologize and then
The List of Demands to get back in their
good graces got longer and longer and
this this is where you know I draw the
line I know the Jewish people have been
through terrible things all over the
world but but but but you can't blame
that on black Americans he just
you just can't
you know what I mean thanks for the one
person that said who
a fair punishment but he should just
post a link to Schindler's List and
y'all write your own captions laughs
it's Kyrie Irving's black ass was
nowhere near the Holocaust
in fact he's not even certain existed
[Laughter]
I saw one
new sponge and screaming about Kanye she
said mental health is no excuse for that
type of language
yes it is [ __ ]
you kill somebody if you're mentally ill
yeah
listen okay I don't think Kanye is crazy
at all I think he's possibly not well
I've been in Hollywood
y'all to get mad at me I'm just telling
you I've been Hollywood this is just
what I saw
it's a lot of juice
like a lot
but that didn't mean anything you know
what I mean there's a lot of black
people in Ferguson Missouri let me run
the place
I could see if you had some kind of
issue you know what I mean he might go
out to Hollywood and you might might
start connecting some kind of lines and
you could maybe adopt the delusion that
the Jews run show business it's not a
crazy thing to think
but it's a crazy thing to say out loud
in a kind of like this
[Laughter]
well earlier this week after Marlon
Brando met with Jewish leaders to
apologize for comments he made on Larry
King live among them that quote
Hollywood is run by Jews the Jewish
leaders accepted the actor's apology and
announced that Brando is now free to
work again
[Music]
you do have oil money in your country
no oil money and you're in the Middle
East
Israeli
well they don't have any oil
dude you're not pissed off they got to
be about that [ __ ]
that's the one bad investment Jews have
made
[Applause]
we'll take this land right here this is
good this is fine trust me this has got
the ocean view everything you need
oh why would you want to be in land what
is Inland nothing important over there
50 years later like maybe we should
expand a little many
maybe we should move in a direction that
has something of value okay our biggest
export is hummus I don't think we are
going to get rich
oh you're Jewish and Iranian
[Applause]
first of all that's a tough one guys
oh that's a rough one dude
cause you got no place that's like home
outside of Beverly Hills
is that is that your daughter no
[Applause]
no
Mubarak
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]